foreign
216th meeting of the Security Council is
called to order
agenda for this meeting is threats to
International Peace and security
the agenda is adopted
in accordance with rule 37 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
I invite the representative of Ukraine
to participate in this meeting
it is so decided
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
I invite the following briefers to
participate in this meeting Miss Izumi
nakamitsu High representative for
disarmament Affairs and Mr Daniel
kovaleck CSO representative
it is so decided
the security Council will now begin its
consideration of item 2 of the agenda
I now give the flow to miss
Izumi nakamitsu
thank you very much Madam president
Madam president distinguished members of
the security Council excellencies ladies
and gentlemen
I have been requested to brief on the
issue of supplies of lethal weapons to
Ukraine and their consequences
this follows a similar briefing I
provided in September to the security
Council
since the Russian invasion of Ukraine on
24th of February 2022
a number of states have transferred
weapon systems and ammunition to Ukraine
for its Defense Forces
this as I noted in September
is a matter of public record
information from governments regarding
their transfers is largely accessible
through open sources
such transfers have included heavy heavy
Conventional Weapons including battle
tanks armored combat Vehicles large
caliber artillery systems missile
systems and crude combat aerial Vehicles
as well as small arms and light weapons
they have also been widespread and
independently verified reports of the
transfer of major Conventional Weapons
Systems to non-state Armed groups
involved in the conflict against Ukraine
including a theory rocket systems
the large-scale influx of weapons into
any situation of armed conflict raises
many concerns for peace and security
including risks of diversion as well as
potential spillover and escalation
measures to counter the potential
diversion of weapons and ammunition will
be key to post conflict recovery and
Regional security and stability as well
as to conflict prevention in other
regions
such measures include pre-transfer risk
assessments and post-shipment controls
including on-site inspections and end
user verification
of equal importance is the need to
safeguard and account for transferred
military equipment
to enhance transparency in arms
transfers the United Nations register of
Conventional Weapons conventional arms
remains a key tool as does the arms
trade treaty
it is also an important tool to track
the influx of weapons and ammunition in
Conflict zones
these are all widely accepted General
policy approaches by member states which
we encourage all to follow
Madam president
Beyond addressing arms transfers
all parties to conflict have a duty to
protect civilians when conducting
military operations
since 24th of February the office of
High Commissioner for human rights has
recorded 17
181 civilian casualties
with the numbers increasingly Rising
most of the civilian deaths and injuries
continue to be caused by the use of
explosive weapons with wide area effects
including attacks by heavy arterium
multiple launch rocket systems missiles
and aircraft
in addition to thousands of civilians
killed and injured we have witnessed the
destruction of Civilian and critical
infrastructure and services especially
using missiles and uncrewed aerial
vehicles
aside on homes schools rows and bridges
destroyed hospitals and health
facilities have also been impacted
the disruption of water gas heating and
electricity caused by Russian attacks on
energy infrastructure is of particular
concern with the onset of winter
bringing a new dimension to the
humanitarian crisis and putting millions
of people at risk
under International humanitarian law
combatants must not direct attacks
against civilians or civilian
infrastructure and must take all
feasible precautions in the conduct of
military operations to avoid or at least
minimize
incidental loss of civilian life injury
to civilians and damage to civilian
objects
since 2007
two secretary generals have expressed
their serious concerns over the
humanitarian impact of explosive weapons
in populated areas
they have consistently called upon
parties to conflict to avoid their use
due to the high likelihood of
indiscriminate effects
last months on
18 November more than 80 States adopted
the political Declaration on
strengthening the protection of
civilians from the humanitarian
consequences arising from the use of
explosive weapons in populated areas
these decoration marks a milestone in
our efforts to better protect civilians
from the consequences of armed conflict
I call on member states to give effect
to this declaration
the past nine months have seen
tremendous devastation
much as a result of the use of heavy
Conventional Weapons
attacks against civilians and civilian
infrastructure must stop
I also urge states to apply effective
Arms Control measures to address the
risks related to Arms transferred I want
to rate rate preventing diversion of
supplied weapons and ammunition is
essential to avoid fueling conflict and
insecurity in the region and Beyond
Madam president distinguished members of
the security Council
the only way to end the suffering and
Devastation in Ukraine is by ending the
war
I appeal
to all member states to make every
effort for peace
I thank you very much for your attention
I thank Miss nakamitsu for her briefing
I now give the floor to Mr Daniel
kovalik
good evening
I'm Madam president thank you uh your
excellencies ladies and gentlemen my
name is Dan kovalik I am a professor of
international human rights at the
University of Pittsburgh School of Law
I've taught there now for 10 years
I graduated from Columbia Law School in
the great city of New York in 1993 and
I've been very involved in human rights
issues human rights cases particularly
in Latin America particularly in
Colombia South America which
has a major problem with arms going into
the wrong hands into the hands of
Guerrilla groups as well as right-wing
paramilitary groups
and so this has been something I've been
following for years and so I want to
share
what I've also been studying and
learning also about uh Ukraine and armed
shipments there and the danger of those
ending up in the wrong hands so with
your
uh forbearance I'll get right down to it
uh first of all I would call your
attention to a study done
um by the German Federal foreign office
the publication the Small Arms survey in
January 2021 called making the rounds
illicit ammunition in Ukraine again this
is from January 2021 this is even before
uh you know the the major conflict began
um earlier this year
and what they say is that the outbreak
of the conflict in eastern Ukraine in
2014 which we have to remember that's
when it really began led to the
widespread proliferation of small arms
light weapons in their ammunition this
ammunition which includes thousands of
grenades Rockets moored arounds and land
mines along with vast quantities of
firearms cartridges has spread to nearly
every oblast region of Ukraine including
area areas located far from the conflict
Zone
and they said that while the Ukrainian
government has taken steps to reduce
trafficking of these arms they said
these are daunting tasks given the share
volume of illicit ammunition and
circulation and the numerous modes of
transport and smuggling techniques used
by traffickers in Ukraine
now while they conclude that at that
time there was not major transfers of
those arms outside of Ukraine they warn
again this is 2021 that said the
barriers to smuggling grenades rockets
and other ammunition out of Ukraine are
hardly insurmountable even a successful
trafficking scheme could radically alter
the profile of illicit weapons in some
countries preventing such schemes and
reducing civilian casualties caused by
loose ammunition in Ukraine will require
a coordinated sustained effort by
Ukrainian authorities and the
International Community for many years
to come this is 2021.
now let's fast forward a bit
so this is a warning really uh given
what comes next and that is the
Intervention which began in February of
2022.
so uh as my colleague said a lot of the
information on this is it can be found
in open sources so here's an article
from April of 2022. this is merely two
months after uh the War uh began uh with
the Russian intervention in February
this is a CNN article what happens to
weapons sent to Ukraine
the U.S really doesn't know that's the
title of the article
and it goes on to explain the US has few
ways to track to suspect a substantial
supply of anti-tank anti-aircraft and
other Weaponry it is sent across the
border into Ukraine
sources tell CNN a blind spot that's due
in large part to the lack of U.S boots
on the ground in the country and the
easy portability of many of the smaller
systems now pouring across the border
it is a conscious risk the Biden
Administration is willing
to
take
and they quote a senior defense official
who said sir this is certainly the
largest reason Supply to a partner
country in a conflict but and at this
time you know uh there was probably 30
billion dollars or so military had had
been sent by the end of January that's
going to probably be about a hundred
billion dollars all told from the U.S
alone right and he says but the risk
both current U.S officials and defense
analysts say is that in the long term
some of those weapons May wind up in the
hands of other militaries and militia
militias the U.S does not intend to arm
so quoting this official he says we have
Fidelity for a short time but when it
enters the fog of War we have almost
zero it drops into a black hole and you
have almost no sense of it at all after
a short period of time
in making the decision to send billions
of dollars of weapons and equipment into
Ukraine the Biden Administration
factored in the risk that some of the
shipments May ultimately end up in
unexpected places
a defense official said
they also quote other officials saying
look the U.S really
does not have a hold over where these
weapons are going they're depending on
Ukraine
for information regarding that and
privately this is according to CNN
officials recognize that Ukraine has an
incentive to give only information that
will bolster their case for more Aid
more arms and more
diplomatic assistance
so in the end again in April the warning
that these arms are going to end up
in places we don't want and of course
they give the example
of Afghanistan where of course the U.S
left in a hurry and left
uh you know how Millions if not billions
of dollars of equipment there and God
knows
uh where that is going to end up by the
way I want to mention before I go on
much further that I just spent a week in
Donetsk
and I did not myself witness illicit
transfers of arms but you know I did see
the effects of arms that apparently went
into the right hands uh and these were
uh ordinances you know shelling
uh done by Ukraine against the school
against the stadium against a place
people go to get water because of course
water is it a premium in Ukraine I'm
sorry in Donetsk in particular because
uh the water filtration system had been
destroyed
uh by Ukrainian forces sometime before
and I've been reading that that
shelling's only increased since I was
there oh by the way a monastery that we
helped to deliver close to that's being
shelled almost daily by Ukraine so while
I'm focusing on illicit arms or arms
going to the lawn people even when it's
going to the white people
is not necessarily ending up in the
right places it's attacking civilians
and that's been happening since 2014 I
want to underscore
and and that's obviously
um a problem
and then uh in June uh sorry August of
2000 sorry June of 2022
you have this article in the guardian of
London
arms sent to Ukraine will end up in
criminal hands says Interpol chief
jurgenstock urges members to cooperate
on arms tracing As Weapons will flood
hidden economy when war ends so he's
saying this with a matter of certainty
jurgenstock says once the conflict ends
a wave of guns and heavy arms will flood
the international market he urged
interposed member states especially
those supplying weapons to cooperate on
arms tracing once the guns fall silent
in Ukraine he said the illegal weapons
will come we know this from many other
theaters of conflict the criminals or
even now as we speak focusing on them
criminal groups again this is still
quoting the head of Interpol criminal
groups try to exploit these chaotic
situations and the availability of
weapons even those used by the military
and including heavy weapons these will
be available on the criminal Market will
create a challenge no country or region
can deal with it in isolation because
these groups operate
at a global level
quote again the same Interpol Chief we
can expect an influx of weapons in
Europe and Beyond we should be alarmed
and we have to expect these weapons to
be trafficked not only to neighboring
countries
but to other continents
August
2022 CBS News did a documentary and they
have an article about the documentary
again why military and Aid in Ukraine
may not always get to the front lines
and they have uh detail
um how
they estimated
back in April
Jonas ohman who's the founder and CEO of
blue yellow lithium lithuanian-based
organization that has been meeting with
and supplying front line units and lot
non-lethal military aid in Ukraine since
the start of the conflict in 2014 said
that back in April he met estimated that
quote 30 just 30 to 40 percent
of the supplies coming across the border
reached its destination
so you're talking about potentially
billions of dollars of equipment not
reaching
the intended
destination
the same article from CBS goes on to say
a combination of Ukraine's constantly
shifting front lines with its largely
volunteer and parap military forces
has made delivery of the military a
difficult for those attempting to
navigate the dangerous supply lines to
their destination
some have raised concerns about weapons
falling into Ukraine's Black Market
which has thrived on corruption since
the collapse of the Soviet Union right
in 1991 so this isn't anything new since
anything we should be surprised about
this is something
um
that we should have been prepared for
but as I go on you'll see that we have
been woefully unprepared
almost willfully
unprepared for this so November 1
2022 The Washington Post
U.S races to track American Arms in heat
of Ukraine war
and what they say is that U.S monitors
have inspected just 10 percent
of high-risk weapons sent to Ukraine
this is incredible this is November
again for months for years they're
saying get a hold of this stuff
in November
a little over a month ago
they're saying wow we probably looked at
about 10 percent of them
uh though they said the uh Biden
Administration hope to achieve a
reasonable level of compliance
uh with over U.S oversight rules but
admitted it would certainly would not
achieve a hundred percent I mean this
again should be troubling
to anyone
um
Rachel stole the vice president for
research programs at the Washington Bay
Stimson Center this is the same article
Washington Post said officials also must
develop long-term plans to ensure the
security of surplus U.S weapons once the
conflict with Russia ends noting again
Ukraine's history as a theater for small
arms smuggling after the Cold War again
this has been going on for decades
the challenges in Ukraine Echo the
larger concerns about how weapons
produced in the U.S the largest global
weapon seller are employed worldwide
Advocates have long complained that
despite systems designed to prevent
their misuse foreign Partners have
sometimes implied those employed those
arms against civilians in places
including Yemen well we know that right
I mean in Yemen uh you know since 2015
the Saudis have used U.S Munitions
including cluster bombs to to attack
civilian uh uh civilians and and
civilian infrastructure
UNESCO historic sites as well
um sophisticated equipment has also
fallen into adversary's hands allowing
the Islamic State to Showcase Abram's
tanks in the Taliban to Pilot Blackhawk
helicopters
again none of this surprising
but what's being done
very little about it
then you have the voice of America okay
this is you know the US itself more or
less speaking quoting the Nigerian
president November 30th 2022.
Ukraine war funneling arms fighter
fighters into Lake Chad basin so the
Nigerian president is complaining this
is already happening
he says the war between Russia and
Ukraine is allowing arms and Fighters
to stream into the late Chad region
bolstering the strength of terrorist
groups of course we saw in the same
region in Chad and the sawhal region of
Africa
uh after the Libyan after the NATO's uh
bombing campaign
and War on Libya
um
illicit arms flooded the sawhal region
and Fighters as well
to stabilize places like Tunisia Chad
Mali and even Syria right you should
read Seymour nurses piece about that
Pulitzer prize-winning Seymour Hirsch's
article uh about that transfer of
Fighters uh to Syria from Libya but in
any case so this is already happening
according to the Nigerian president
um weapons from Ukraine are already
ending up
in the hands of extremists finally in
terms of of what I'm relying on you can
look at an interesting uh opinion piece
in the hill
um publication
uh from thehill.com this is uh November
or sorry December 7th this is two days
ago 2022 preventing U.S weapons from
escaping Ukraine is a challenge
again underscoring the difficulty if not
impossibility of getting a handle on all
these weapons which goes back to the
first report saying we need
International oversight over this
and with respect and I'm an American
so I can say this
uh the U.S isn't going to do it
in fact two days ago the same day this
was written
a house committee
that was considering whether to do an
audit
on UK you know uh weapons transfers to
Ukraine and money sent to you crane
um that resolution was voted down
Congress affirmatively decided we're not
going to audit the billions and billions
of dollars of Weaponry we're sending to
Ukraine
as an American taxpayer I can say
I don't like that but I would think as
the security Council in charge of
maintaining International Peace and
security you shouldn't like that
who is watching The Watchman here
it is the job of the security Council to
do that I urge you to do that because
um running short of time may I request
you to be uh to round off as soon as you
can thank you yes I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna wind up right now I just want
to reiterate the comments of my
colleague who opened this session
saying that what really has to happen is
the end of this war a negotiated end of
this war which I think is possible we
know back in March or April there was
apparently a deal that both sides could
have lived with
that apparently Boris Johnson from the
UK went and told zielinski not to sign
but apparently there is a deal some way
to end this conflict this needs to be
ended
and it needs to be added through
negotiated settlement and again I urge
the security Council to work towards
that end thank you very much
thank you very much Mr kovalik for your
briefing
I now give the floor to those council
members who wish to make statements I
give the flow to
the Russian Federation
is
foreign
Associates
results
organizations
University
is
Germania
foreign
new grains
stories
foreign
[Applause]
instructors
yesterday
in the company
analysis
regime
that is
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
foreign
story
foreign
University
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
bukhari
foreign
foreign
foreign
stage
this is
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
videos
I thank Russia for their statement and I
would now like to give the floor to the
representative of Novi
thank you madam president and I thank
the briefers for their statements
I will make Five Short points
first we condemn Russia's war against
Ukraine in the strongest possible terms
and second we reiterate our unwavering
support for Ukraine Serenity and
territorial Integrity within its
internationally recognized borders
Ukraine has a right to self-defense as
enshrined in article 51 of the U.N
Charter as well as the Sovereign right
to ask for and receive support from
other states in the exercise of this
right
Norway will continue to stand with
Ukraine
third Russia's war against Ukraine is a
blatant violation of international law
including the U.N Charter
it is a violation of the core principle
on which this organization is built
The Sovereign equality of its members
and the inadmissibility of the
acquisition of territory by force
Russia must abide by international law
and stop its war of aggression now
fourth we are alarmed by the recent
increase in Russian attacks on civilians
and civilian infrastructure
the massive waves of missiles and drone
strikes on Ukraine clearly demonstrates
Russia's complete disregard for the
horrible suffering they are causing
millions of people
in addition to causing casualties these
cynical attacks have destroyed a large
number number of power facilities
leaving Ukraine's population freezing in
the middle of the winter
children persons with disabilities and
the elderly are in particularly
vulnerable situations they must be
protected
fifth under transfer a lethal weapons
from Iran by Russia
we recall that all states are obligated
to respect the restrictions of
resolution 2231
the use of drones from Iran adds even
further to the list of Russia's total
disregard for international law the U.N
Charter and the decisions of the very
Security Council on which it sits as a
permanent member
and finally Madam president Russia is
the one driving weapons flows weapon
flows into Ukraine and they do so
through their illegal war against
Ukraine
almost one year has gone since Russia
aggressive Invasion and it's not too
late for them to do the right thing
to respect the U.N Charter to withdraw
all troops and to work for a peaceful
solution through dialogue and diplomatic
efforts I thank you
I thank the representative of Novi and I
give the flow now to the United Kingdom
thank you president and I thank the high
representative for disarmament Affairs
for her briefing
uh president I will be brief because we
discussed Russia's war of aggression in
Ukraine uh just three days ago
during that meeting
we heard under Secretary General
Griffith's harrowing account of the
horrific consequences of Russia's war
and his deep concerns about the impacts
of Russia's systematic attacks on
Ukraine's infrastructure and civilian
centers
particularly ahead of winter
we've just seen further oh CHR reporting
on potential atrocities against
civilians committed by Russia
the irony
given the topic of this meeting
is that Russia is perpetrating this war
including with weapons sourced from Iran
in violation of resolution 2231
and is almost certainly
seeking to Source Weaponry from other un
sanctioned States
like North Korea
as its own stocks dwindle
we note
that despite the resounding calls in
this Council again on Tuesday
for a ceasefire
and for peace
dialogue and diplomacy
the Russian president on Wednesday
doubled down
confirming that The Invasion would
continue
and that it would be protracted
he also reaffirmed the Neo imperialist
nature of the campaign
claiming that unlike Peter the Great
he had made the Sea of azov a Russian
internal sea
president
in the face of Russia's Relentless
effort
to seize Ukraine's territory in
violation of the UN Charter
and to dehumanize
kill and subjugate its people
Ukraine has no choice
but to exercise its right to defend
itself
if it did not
it would cease to exist
in a similar situation
all of us would do the same
and due to the Deep determination to
live
Ukraine is prevailing
the UK is proud of the support it is
providing to Ukrainian people in the
face of this aggression
defensive support
humanitarian support
an assistance to rebuild critical
infrastructure destroyed by Russian
attacks
president
Russia can end this suffering
immediately
by ceasing attacks against Ukraine
including critical National
infrastructure and innocent civilians
and withdrawing all of its forces
illegally present in Ukraine
we welcome and support Ukraine's
Initiative for a just and sustainable
peace
we again join the International
Community
in calling on Russia
to similarly commit to meaningful
dialogue and negotiations
based on upholding Ukraine's rights
under international law and the UN
Charter
thank you president
I thank the representative of the United
Kingdom for their statement and I now
give the floor to the representative of
Ghana thank you madam president
for her briefing my delegation has also
taken note of the information provided
by the Civil Society representative Mr
Daniel kovalik
I begin my statement by reaffirming
Ghana's complete and unwavering
commitment to the sovereignty political
Independence and territorial Integrity
of Ukraine and affirm Ukraine's inherent
right to self-defense under customary
international law codified in chapter 7
of the United Nations Charter the
stability of our International system
has been carefully built upon
established Norms of Interstate
relations one of which is the Cardinal
prohibition of the use of force by one
State against the other
any contrary actions as we have
witnessed of the Russian Federation
agree against Ukraine undermine the
fundamental principles of international
law the values and the purposes of the
United Nations Charter and constitutes
U.S threats to International Peace and
security
over the past nine months Ukraine has
deployed its military and strategic
capabilities in asserting its inherent
right to self-defense against the armed
attack of the Russian Federation and in
a courageous Endeavor to preserve its
national interests to such action there
is no prohibition and neither do the
rules of international law or the
charter prohibits the supply of
Conventional Weapons to a state under
the armed attack of another
regrettably the war has come at the
great cost of Destruction damage and the
loss of lives and with each passing day
of missile attacks the toll of Civilian
casualties and damage to Ukraine's
critical infrastructure continues to
compound as the United Nations
registered some of the worst
humanitarians statistics since World War
II we also remain acutely aware of the
looming danger of a nuclear catastrophe
as the Integrity of this operation
nuclear power plant is persistently
violated
away from Ukraine the world has spared
unprecedented levels of global energy
food and financial crisis which have
derailed the capacity of many developing
States rebound from the impact of the
global covid-19 pandemic further Western
socio-economic conditions for many
communities far removed from the theater
of war it remains in our common interest
to end the war and the trail of
Devastation that is living in its path
it is therefore a view that the
preoccupation of the International
Community should be the immediate
cessation of military hostilities a key
aspect of which is the unconditional
withdrawal of Russian forces from the
internationally recognized borders of
Ukraine we retrate our call on the
Russian Federation to end its aggression
against Ukraine and to respect its
sovereignty and territorial Integrity in
line with the norms and principles of
international law while diplomatic
efforts to end the war may appear to
have that the International Community we
must remain steadfast and unified in our
efforts to facilitate a political
dialogue with credible guarantees of
addressing the respective security
concerns of the parties in its enduring
wisdom the chapter of the United Nations
Avail several modes of Pacific
settlement which promised to deliver our
present and Collective aspiration for
peace in Ukraine if undertaking with a
genuine commitment and greater
determination of the warring sides and
all stakeholders we must pursue the path
of dialogue as there can be no military
solution to the conflict finally we urge
the parties to uphold the rules of
international humanitarian law in
particular the requirements for
distinction and proportionality to avoid
causing needle and needless harm to
civilians and civilian infrastructure I
thank you
I thank Ghana for their statement and I
now give the flow to the representative
of China
Italian
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[ __ ] with enjoy
I thank the representative of France of
China excuse me and I now give the floor
to France
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
digression
solo the
respective programs
resolution
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
economic politics
the
solution example
is justice
foreign
foreign
I give the floor to the representative
of the United Arab Emirates
Madam president
I thank under Secretary General
nakamitsu for her briefing and we
listened carefully to Mr kovalik's
remarks
when the council last considered the
issue of arms transfers in the context
of the conflict in Ukraine three months
ago we expressed Our concern that the
risk of these arms transfers would be
compounded if both sides were intent on
achieving a military Victory and the
conflict were to become a protracted one
unfortunately the prospects of reaching
a negotiated settlement have not grown
appreciably closer in the intervening
months
still there have been signals of a
widening recognition that talks are the
inevitable path to adorable peace
the UAE is steadfast in its belief that
there simply is no military solution to
the war a sustainable end will have to
come through negotiations
with that in mind as the war continues
we must mitigate the attendant risks
in all military conflicts it is vital to
safeguard weapons during transfer
storage and deployment so they may not
inadvertently fall into the wrong hands
particularly terrorist groups
on that note the UE welcomes
announcements of efforts to mitigate
risks associated with arms transfers
that includes plans tailored to the
transfer of high-tech weapon systems and
Regional programs to enhance
anti-trafficking capabilities in the
region
we also welcome other recent initiatives
aimed at strengthening illicit arms
trade prevention related to the conflict
in Ukraine
the volume and type of arms involved in
this case necessitate greater vigilance
and transparency
we support calls such as that by the
High Commissioner for disarmament
Affairs today for Effective Arms Control
measures
Madam president war is not only inhumane
and causes Untold suffering but it is
also fraught with unintended
consequences
the council has a responsibility for the
maintenance of International Peace and
security and an obligation to ukrainians
and people around the world
for its part the UAE continues to
actively support and facilitate
mediation and de-escalatory confidence
building measures and we stand ready to
support all efforts towards a peaceful
resolution thank you madam president
I thank the representative of the United
Arab Emirates for their statement and I
now give the flow to Albania
thank you madam president I thank our
representative nakamitsu for her
information
since the very beginning of this war we
have permanently pointed out the very
key aspect of the war in Ukraine it is a
war of choice an aggression against
another country a blunt violation of
international law and the charter of the
United Nations
everything else we hear or say about
developments in Ukraine derives from
this
in return since the very first day
Ukraine has defended itself has resisted
has pushed back the aggressor and has
called the world for help
ing Ukraine to defend itself from a
brutal war is a moral duty
it is also an essential security
imperative since Russia's actions
undermine seriously European and Global
Security and stability
Albania is proud to be among those doing
what it can to help Ukraine and
ukrainians
we are assisting a country whose very
existence is under threat to resist and
escape to the war it has not chosen
international law is crystal clear a
country under attack has every right to
defend itself
under article 51 of the United Nations
Charter
Ukraine has been under attack for 10
months and is simply defending itself
it's sovereignty it's territorial
integrity and this political
Independence have been assaulted
which makes self-defense not only a
natural right but also an existential
imperative therefore whoever is helping
Ukraine in whatever way legally and
openly is helping not only a nation in
need a nation in danger a nature under
threat there are also upholding the law
and protecting the U.N Charter
therefore the issue here is not what
means Ukraine is provided to resist
aggression in fact as we are called to
speak about lethal weapons the real and
very disturbing issue is the transfer of
killing drones to Russia by Iran
in flagrant violation of paragraph 4 and
XP of Security Council resolution 2231
these drones first denied and later
later admitted delivered by Iran and
used by Russia to attack civilians and
civilians
infrastructure throughout Ukraine are
the real question the one that needs a
clear answer
we expect the Secretary General in
implementing resolution 2231 to provide
soon a full report on the matter
Madam President we have said it before
and want to reiterate instead of abusing
the time and resources of this council
with meetings like this one today we
should concentrate on real issues
as we speak Russian attacks are causing
casualties destroying civil
infrastructure in particular the energy
Supply system leaving millions of people
without access to electricity heat and
water punishing everyone without
distinction
and this constitutes a violation of
International International humanitarian
law
those who disrespect the law must face
consequences Those who commit crimes
must be held accountable therefore Madam
president I would like to conclude by
saying that nothing even less an
overused and consumed false narrative
prevents anyone to see the terrible
reality in Ukraine the crimes committed
there but more than anything the need to
stand in full solidarity with Ukraine
it's resistant and it's right the right
to decide on its policies to choose his
friends and this future thank you I
thank the representative of Albania and
I now give the flow to the
representative of Kenya
thank you madam president
I thank USG Izumi nakamitsu and Mr
kovalik for their briefings
we take notes with extreme concern the
Rooney has damaged the war cause is
causing in Ukraine's lives Ukraine's
legitimate right to sovereignty and
territorial integrity and Regional and
International Security
as the council debates the conduct of
War
as we have done so often including two
days ago we must reiterate our calls
that every effort be deployed to stop it
we must be more responsive to our
fundamental mandate to maintain
International Peace and security
comprehensively
we acknowledge the AV responsibility
Ukraine must bear in defending defensing
our internationally recognized borders
while
conscripting training and arming one's
Army in times of war is expected
the impact of proliferation of weapons
is bound to have a big impact not only
in the country in Conflict but also
Beyond
Madam president
we are faced with a multi-prolonged
global crisis from the war in Ukraine
besides the magnitude of food insecurity
threatening especially developing
countries and a more complicated
multilateral order we must now move to
urgently address the unprecedented
proliferation of weapons
none of these challenges can be
effectively addressed with the world
raging on
as the first and foremost effective step
the world needs to end
Kenya therefore
calls for specific and sustained efforts
to reach arrangements to deliver a
minimum level level of the escalation
and the confliction while establishing
channels of dialogue that will lead to
stability
finally Madam president
we again call for a cessation of
hostilities
and for a political settlement that
respects the soviety territorial
integrity and political independence of
Ukraine I thank you
representative of Kenya for their
statement I give the flow to the United
States
for your informative briefing this
morning
we all know that actions speak louder
than words but before we discuss
Russia's actions let's discuss Russia's
words here in the council today
it continues to confound my delegation
that we are all once again brought into
this Council to devote our attention
to Russia's fictions
in the midst of and in spite of its war
of aggression against its neighbor
Ukraine Russia has wasted wasted
countless hours of the council's time
on fictional dirty bombs in Ukraine
acclaimed debunked repeatedly by the
iaea inspectors
they wasted our time on fictional
biological weapons
supposedly be to be delivered to
Ukraine's near Neighbors on the wings of
birds and bats
claims rejected by this Council and
rejected by the state's parties to the
biological weapons convention
Russia uses these stories these words to
try to distract us from its own
aggression
for example Russia claims that its
forces are not committing atrocities
when there's a host of credible reports
reports from a broad range of sources
that members of its forces have
committed rape torture and summary
executions in Ukraine
Russia has not come here today to
present us with any credible Solutions
and these are not incredible accusations
what we are seeing is frustrated on the
battlefield
Russia has resorted to destroying
Ukraine's critical and energy
infrastructure from afar
causing immense suffering to civilians
as we heard just three days ago
and defying the international
community's call to end its aggression
despite all of this Russia has the gall
to demand today in the council that the
International Community watched from the
sidelines as Moscow seeks the
destruction of another U.N member state
Western assistance to Ukraine is in the
face of Russia's illegal brutal invasion
is not the problem here
it is Russia's Invasion itself
that is the one attribute common to all
of Russia's fictions to all its words
to find any distraction no matter how
odious no matter how transparently false
to try to shift our Focus
from the immense and needless suffering
Russia has caused and continues to cause
to the people of Ukraine
it is Russia that has cynically called
for this meeting alleging an illicit
conspiracy of weapons transfers from
Ukraine
when in fact as others around this table
have noted it is Russia that is
complicit in Iran's illegal transfer of
unmanned aerial vehicles
to Russia in violation of Security
Council resolution 2231 Annex B
Russia continues to use these Iranian
uavs and its war against Ukraine and
attacks against civilian infrastructure
in cities which have led to the deaths
of civilians
let me be clear
we've seen no credible evidence of
diversion of U.S provided equipment we
heard no credible evidence of diversion
this afternoon in this Council
we would certainly review evidence to
support these claims whether it came
from a head of state
or international law enforcement
official if it is produced
we would do that because the United
States takes very seriously our
responsibility to protect our defense
and dual use Technologies and to prevent
their diversion
at the same time the United States is
committed to continuing to support the
people of Ukraine as they defend their
country and their freedom
we are not hiding this support
as others have said Ukraine has every
right to defend itself and we have every
right to continue our long-standing
support to its defense
though we have seen no credible evidence
of Ukraine diverting U.S origin arms and
munitions
we must all recognize an inherent risk
of weapons capture and diversion on the
battlefield and any armed conflict
we have always taken and the United
States continues to take proactive steps
to mitigate this risk
what we have seen is Western origin
systems captured by Russia in Ukraine
Russia is in fact the only known Vector
of diversion Russia has an incentive to
spread disinformation about diversion
and indeed to actually divert U.S
weapons in order to create a false
narrative about our assistance
that spuriously discredits Ukraine and
seeks to weaken international support
for Ukraine self-defense
the Ukrainian government has committed
to appropriately safeguarding and
accounting for transfer defense
equipment
it is important that we remind ourselves
that this equipment is vital to
Ukraine's defense and so Ukraine has a
strong incentive to protect it
we welcome the Ukrainian government's
formation of a commission to strengthen
the monitoring of donated military
equipment just this summer
we continue to work closely with our
Ukrainian government partners
to ensure all assistance continues to be
properly used and safeguarded
as Ukraine defends its sovereignty and
territorial Integrity against Russia's
ongoing aggression
helping Ukraine keep and regain control
of its Sovereign territory is an
important factor in limiting potential
illicit diversion by Russia's forces
Russia's proxies criminal groups
terrorist organizations or other
non-state actors
consistent with our commitment to the
serious responsibility of safeguarding
against diversion in October the United
States government published the U.S plan
to counter illicit diversion of certain
Advanced Conventional Weapons in Eastern
Europe
this was a comprehensive whole of
government approach that also engages
our allies and partners
while this is a recent publication it is
not a new plan we've been working to
address the risk of diversion since well
before last February including in close
cooperation with our allies and key
partners
this plan has three main lines of effort
we'll quickly first working with
Ukraine's authorities to Monitor and
control sensitive and dangerous arms
secondly strengthening border controls
inside and around Ukraine and third
enhancing law enforcement capability in
neighboring countries
Madam president while the Russian
government is heavily invested in
spreading disinformation to justify and
distract the International Community
from Russia's unprovoked war against
Ukraine we and our allies remain firmly
committed to supporting Ukraine as it
defends its territorial integrity and
civilian population against Russia's
aggression and so we take these
allegations of diversion of U.S origin
weapons from Russia's officials or
pro-kremlin sources with a healthy dose
of skepticism
I will conclude on the subject of
diversion with a statement of fact
the most effective path toward reducing
conflict and any risk of illicit
diversion of arms would be for Russia
to end the war that it started in
withdraw its forces from all of
Ukraine's Sovereign territory
this may begin to relieve Russia of its
dependence on its many corrosive
fictions
thank you madam president
I thank the representative of the United
States for their statement I give the
flow to Gabon
foreign
Ukraine
foreign
infrastructure civil
foreign
foreign
a person
is
I thank the representative of Gabon for
their statement I give the flow to
Mexico
mucha gracias Senora president
attention
alas implications
[Music]
ukrania
and those milcators
utilizadas conflicto
ES omnipresented
ES
infrastructura
includos hospitales
entomado
armas
transferences control
s
circumstances
organizations criminals
implications
tripolas
independent Elementary
the organization Small Arms survey
reflex
foreign
book
s
information
is
foreign
personas
foreign
associated
Conseco
radio
military
una solution
National
same forking impromover Mass
es
the mediation
president
Fronteras International
I thank Mexico for their statement and I
now give the floor to Brazil
thank you madam president and I would
like to thank High representative izumo
nakamitsu and Mr kovalik for their
inputs
Madam president over the years
this Council has sought to incorporate
into its agenda issues whose
relationship with International Peace
and security is not always clear
interestingly the Nexus between weapons
and armed conflict has received less
attention
this linkage is explicitly recognized by
the main instrument of international law
on conventional arms exports the arms
trade treaty which commits exporting
states to consider whether arms
transfers would contribute to or
undermine peace and security
on the other hand all states have the
inherent right to self-defense as
enshrined in the U.N Charter and
consequently the right to acquire arms
for their security including from
outside sources
it should also be recalled that the ATT
explicitly prohibits transfers of arms
and ammunition that would be used in the
commission of genocide crimes against
humanity grave breaches of the Geneva
conventions of 1949 a tax directed
against civilian objects or civilians
protected as such
or other war crimes
in the past years we have witnessed the
phenomenon of the growing urbanization
of conflicts the increasing involvement
of non-state actors
and the use of methods and means of war
that do not comply with the principles
of Distinction and proportionality
additionally we see a risk regarding the
problem of illicit trafficking of
Conventional Weapons and ammunition
the weapons now being used in the
conflict in Ukraine will possibly fuel
in the future other conflicts in
different regions of the world
as to the case in point it should be
recognized that the supply of arms and
ammunition to the parties to the
conflict in Ukraine might result in
prolonging it and in more suffering for
the civilian population
on the other hand it is undeniable that
the state has a right to self-defense in
case of violation of its sovereignty and
its territorial Integrity it is a
principle enshrined in the U.N Charter
this discussion however this destructs
distracts us from fulfilling our mandate
which is to maintain peace and security
and therefore work towards a ceasefire
and negotiations
we must bear in mind that International
humanitarian law norms and principles
are mandatory at all times and under all
circumstances
respecting and ensuring respect for
international humanitarian law is not
only a legal obligation but also an
effective way to protect civilians
Madam president article 33 of the U.N
Charter a science to the council the
responsibility to explore Avenues of
dialogue in favor of the peaceful
solution of disputes and I quote the
security Council shall when it deems
necessary call upon the parties to
settle their disputes by such means
end quote
after more than nine months of conflict
in Ukraine we must recognize that this
body has still to fulfill its mandate
Brazil is concerned that signs of
openness to dialogue have been in short
supply
last July the Black Sea Green initiative
provided in the words of USG Rosemary
DeCarlo a Beacon of Hope
for all in face of a global food crisis
there have also been occasional
arrangements to exchange prisons of War
the harsh reality however is that the
belief in the feasibility of military
solution continues to be present and not
only by the parties to the conflict
whatever the cost in terms of human
suffering
Madam president once again we reiterate
the call for an immediate ceasefire
without preconditions
saving human lives must take precedence
over any consideration including the
just desire for reparations and
punishing those responsible for war
crimes
Brazil adds its voice to those of other
members in favor of dialogue and recalls
that the world looks to this Council in
the expectation that it will fully
exercise its responsibility to stop this
spiral of violence I thank you madam
president
I thank Brazil for their statement I
give the floor to Ireland
thank you madam president and thank you
hi representative nakamitsu for your
briefing I know the presence of Mr
kobalik
Madam president the facts surrounding
the war in Ukraine are clear Ukraine was
a peaceful independent country
Russia chose to open that peace and to
violate Ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity
it did so in 2014 when in the illegally
annexed Crimea
it did so again this year when it
launched its brutal war of regression
what is less clear is the justification
for today's meeting called by the
Russian Federation
Ukraine did not commit or threaten to
commit an armed attack against Russia
it was Russia which attacked Ukraine and
which cynically sought to justify its
Invasion by invoking article 51 of the
U.N Charter
it is Russia which now seeks to deny
Ukraine its entirely legitimate right of
self-defense as enshrined in the U.N
Charter
Ireland along with all EU member states
rigorously implements our International
obligations
we apply the EU common position under
which EU member states assess exports of
military technology and Equipment
against a range of criteria including a
specific Criterion on risk of diversion
attempts by the Russian Federation to
frame this urgent unnecessary support
for Ukraine's defense as an uncontrolled
supply of weapons are once again a port
attempt at obfuscating the Grievous
actions
the EU and its member states are
determined to support to support Ukraine
for as long as it takes
we are greatly concerned by the manner
in which Russia is acquiring and using
unmanned aerial vehicles in Ukraine as
well as reports of ballistic missiles
obtained from Iran in contravention and
resolution 2231.
the comment by the dprk ambassador to
Moscow that his country is to supply
Russia with ballistic missiles in
contravention of resolution 1718 is also
of serious concern
Russia's actions risk undermining these
essential resolutions and the authority
of this Council
for its part Ukraine has sought to
restore peace
president zielinski has offered a road
map to peace his 10-point peace plan to
end this senseless War
Russia has responded with a barrage of
missile strikes bringing further death
and destruction further worsening the
humanitarian crisis which Russia's War
has caused
Madam President we ask that Russia
stopped trying to use this Council as a
platform for his disinformation
paint itself as the victim of its own
aggression in the face of the heinous
actions it has committed
instead of using this information to
falsely blame others Russia should seek
his aggression against Ukraine and
should do so immediately
Ireland once again calls on Russia to
withdraw its troops and engage in good
faith in dialogue and diplomacy to bring
about a peaceful resolution of the
conflict in line with international law
and the U.N Charter
millions of lives in Ukraine depend upon
this thank you
thank you I would now like to deliver
the following remarks in my national
capacity at the outset we thank under
Secretary General for disarmament
Affairs Miss Izumi nakamitsu for her
detailed briefing
the trajectory of the Ukraine conflict
is a matter of profound concern for the
entire International Community we
believe that internationally agreed
principles and regimes should be
respected and upheld by all countries
this Council would recall that since the
commencement of the conflict in Ukraine
India has been consistently calling for
an immediate cessation of hostilities
and for an end to violence
we have emphasized that dialogue and
diplomacy are the only way forward
actions that exacerbate the conflict
should be avoided rather all efforts
should be made to de-escalate and bring
both sides to the negotiating table as
our prime minister has said today's era
is not an era of war in a globalized
world the impact of the conflict has not
just been limited to Europe we've all
experienced its consequences in terms of
surging costs and shortages of food
grains fertilizers and fuel the global
South in particular is feeling the pain
acutely we must therefore not initiate
measures that further complicate the
struggling global economy on our part we
are providing humanitarian assistance to
Ukraine and economic support to our
neighbors under economic distress we
very much hope that the International
Community will continue to respond
positively to the call for humanitarian
assistance India has dispatched 12
Consignments of humanitarian Aid to
Ukraine so far and we stand ready to do
more India's approach will be to promote
dialogue and diplomacy with an
overarching aim to end the ongoing
conflict and work with other partners to
mitigate emerging economic challenges
particularly to the developing countries
colleagues it is in our Collective
interest to work constructively both
inside the United Nations and outside
towards seeking an early resolution to
this conflict in conclusion I reiterate
that the global order is anchored in the
principles of the UN Charter
international law and respect for the
sovereignty and territorial Integrity of
states
thank you
I now resume my duties as the president
of the council
the representative of the Russian
Federation has asked for the floor to
make a further statement
I give them the flow
is
foreign
foreign
foreign
microphone
foreign
I thank the representative of Russia
for their statement
I now give the flow to the
representative of Ukraine
well thank you madam president
distinguished members of the security
Council under Secretary General
nakamitsu I also recognize the remainder
of Representatives of terrorist Russia
independent seat of the Soviet Union
it is becoming grotesque
and soon
it won't be a surprise
to see Leo tolstoy's major work called
Special Operation and peace
to comply with Putin's laws
after all it is also a mix of fictional
narrative
history and often perverse philosophy
like many Russian statements in this
chamber
if somebody
right in your face
tells you
that and I quote
eastern Ukraine had good reason to join
Russia
end of quote
or an even more delusional quote
Russia's intervention in Ukraine is
legal on the international law
end of quote
who in their right mind would refer to
the author of these statements as an
authoritative Source in This Global
Watchdog of international law and order
of course there is freedom of speech in
this country
including through for alumni of
otherwise respectable University
before for God's sake
even in a city where cannabis is now
legal
there is no need to fill this chamber
with the smoke of conspiracy spam
Russia again attempts to legitimize its
flagrant violations
of the U.N Charter by using the council
as a platform
for circulating is propaganda narratives
it is a very simple algorithm that
Moscow has
explored since Soviet times
but as you said yourself Mr kovalik
you are an American
and you can say what you want
of course you can
but why in the world do you waste our
time
neither American taxpayers
no hours
do approve this frittering away their
money
of course you can
but why in the world do you waste our
time
neither American taxpayers
let me remind you
it hardly covers these debauchery
first you have to blame the victim
and
vegetable Nations
three six and numbers
all these are supposed to make fakes
look like facts
in particular
we have never heard
me in the places where
the more ukrainians can be saved
we will therefore continue to deoccupy
our Sovereign territories in strict
accordance with article 51 of the UN
Charter
any other option would be a betrayal of
our competitors who have been compelled
to stay in the occupied territories and
now waiting for liberation
we are grateful to all friends and
allies who support Ukraine in these
Noble endeavor
including by supplying modern weapons
their use has been an element of Ukraine
exercising the inherent right to
self-defense under the above-mentioned
article 51 of the U.N Charter
Madam president Russia brought the same
allegations to the attention of the
security Council on the 8th of September
let me remind you what happened
afterwards
the Armed Forces of Ukraine launched its
operation to liberate the east and south
of the country
since September
thousands of square kilometers in harkib
hersson and luhansk regions were
liberated
this is the most powerful and viable
evidence that all weapons in Ukraine's
possession serve their intended purpose
to help Ukrainian soldiers to liberate
our people and our territories
to prevent the illegal use Ukraine has
created and ensured the effective
functioning of a multi-level system of
Arms Control
it is carried out in in out on three
tracks
circulation and use of small arms and
light weapons
expert control and control and
supervision of weapons and military
equipment transferred by foreign
countries
circulation and use of small arms and
light weapons has been controlled on an
interagency level that includes the
ministry of interior
security service state border Service as
well as other governmental structures
responsible for combating illegal arms
trafficking
the state service of Ukraine for export
control as well as inter-agency
Commission on Military and Technical
cooperation and expert control are
responsible for practical implementation
of the state policy in the area of
expert control over International
transfers of dual use and military goods
as well as implementation of measures to
prevent their use for terrorists and
other illegal purposes
Ukraine has also established a
three-level system control and
supervision of weapons supplied by our
foreign partners
the Parliamentary oversight is carried
out
by the temporary special Commission
the president exercises its
constitutional duties through the
National Security and defense Council of
Ukraine
a special system called Sota has been
implemented there to monitor weapons and
equipment supplied by Foreign Partners
makes it makes it possible to receive
information about every single sample of
such weapons
at the governmental level the ministry
of defense and armed forces of Ukraine
together with foreign Partners carry out
Direct Control and monitoring including
through the use of logistics functional
area Services System lockfas
lockfas allows the monitoring of armed
supplies to Ukraine as well as the
movement of international technical
assistance
in addition
Auditors of the ministry of Defense of
Ukraine carry out field inspections of
weapons supplied by Foreign partners
at the same time we remain extremely
concerned about the activities of
illegal armed formations including the
infamous Wagner group
in the temporarily occupied territories
of Ukraine
these formations widely recruit people
with criminal backgrounds in Russia and
use weapons that are not subject to any
control mechanisms including internal
Russian ones
given the fact that Wagner group is
reported to operate on on other
continents as well the threat of illicit
arms trafficking stemming from the
activities of Russian private military
companies is more than real and worse
being addressed by the council and
relevant International mechanisms
in eastern Ukraine the Ukrainian side
both its civil and Military
Representatives
demonstrates transparency
and commitment
to cooperating fully with our partners
as well as within International expert
control regimes
who will continue to act in this vein as
it is fully in line with our main task
full the occupation of the Sovereign
territory of Ukraine within its
International recognized borders
following the defeat of Russia
and the end of the war
the demilitarization and
denuclearization of Russia should take
place
it will prevent the threat of the
repetition of aggression thus laying a
solid foundation for both the
transformation of Russia into a
peace-loving nation and for ensuring
sustainable peace and security and I
thank you
I thank the representative of Ukraine
for their statement
there are no more names inscribed on the
list of speakers
the meeting is adjourned